what keeps us
healthy and happy as we go through life
if you were going to invest now in your
future best self
where would you put your time and your
energy
there was a recent survey of millennials
asking them
what their most important life goals
were
and over 80 percent said that a major
life goal for them
was to get rich and another 50 percent
of those same young adults said that
another major life goal
was to become famous
and we're constantly told to lean in to
work
to push harder
and achieve more we're given the
impression that these are the things
that we need to go after in order to
have a good life
pictures of entire lives of the choices
that people make
and how those choices work out for them
those pictures are almost impossible to
get
most of what we know about human life we
know from asking people to remember the
past
and as we know hindsight is anything but
2020. we forget vast amounts of what
happens to us in life
and sometimes memory is downright
creative
but what if we could watch
entire lives as they unfold
through time what if we could study
people from the time
that they were teenagers all the way
into old age
to see what really keeps people happy
and healthy
we did that the harvard study of adult
development
may be the longest study of adult life
that's ever been done for 75
years we've tracked the lives of 724 men
year after year asking about their work
their home lives their health
and of course asking all along the way
without knowing how their life stories
were going to turn out
studies like this are exceedingly rare
almost all projects of this kind fall
apart within a decade
because too many people drop out of the
study
or funding for the research dries up or
the researchers get distracted or they
die
and nobody moves the ball further down
the field
but through a combination of luck and
the persistence of several generations
of researchers
this study has survived about 60 of our
original 724
men are still alive still participating
in the study
most of them in their 90s and we are now
beginning to study the more than 2
000 children of these men
and i'm the fourth director of the study
since 1938 we've tracked the lives of
two groups of men
the first group started in the study
when they were sophomores at harvard
college
they all finished college during world
war ii and then most went off to serve
in the war
and the second group that we've followed
was a group of boys
from boston's poorest neighborhoods boys
who were chosen for the study
specifically because they were from some
of the most troubled
and disadvantaged families in the boston
of the 1930s
most lived in tenements many without hot
and cold running water
when they entered the study all of these
teenagers
were interviewed they were given medical
exams
we went to their homes and we
interviewed their parents
and then these teenagers grew up into
adults who entered all walks of life
they became factory workers and lawyers
and
bricklayers and doctors one president of
the united states
some developed alcoholism a few develop
schizophrenia
some climbed the social ladder from the
bottom
all the way to the very top and some
made that journey in the opposite
direction
the founders of this study would
never in their wildest dreams have
imagined that i would be standing here
today
75 years later telling you that the
study
still continues every two years
our patient and dedicated research staff
calls up our men
and asks them if we can send them yet
one more set of questions about their
lives
many of the inner city boston men ask us
why do you keep wanting to study me my
life just isn't that interesting
the harvard men never asked that
question
[Laughter]
to get the clearest picture of these
lives we
don't just send them questionnaires we
interview them in their living rooms we
get their medical records from their
doctors
we draw their blood we scan their brains
we talk to their children
we videotape them talking with their
wives about their deepest concerns
and when about a decade ago we finally
asked the wives if they would join us as
members of the study
many of the women said you know it's
about time
so what have we learned what are the
lessons that come
from the tens of thousands of pages of
information that we've generated
on these lives well the lessons aren't
about
wealth or fame or working harder and
harder
the clearest message that we get from
this 75-year study is this
good relationships keep us happier and
healthier
period we've learned three big lessons
about relationships the first is that
social connections
are really good for us and that
loneliness kills
it turns out that people who are more
socially connected
to family to friends to community
are happier they're physically healthier
and they live longer than people who are
less well
connected and the experience of
loneliness turns out to be toxic
people who are more isolated than they
want to be from others
find that they are less happy
their health declines earlier in
mid-life their brain functioning
declines sooner and they live shorter
lives
than people who are not lonely and the
sad fact
is that at any given time more than one
in five
americans will report that they're
lonely
and we know that you can be lonely in a
crowd and
you can be lonely in a marriage so the
second big lesson that we learned
is that it's not just the number of
friends you have
and it's not whether or not you're in a
committed relationship
but it's the quality of your close
relationships
that matters it turns out that living in
the midst of conflict is really bad for
our health
high conflict marriages for example
without much affection
turn out to be very bad for our health
perhaps
worse than getting divorced and living
in the midst of good warm relationships
is protective once we had followed our
men
all the way into their 80s we want to
look back at them at midlife
and to see if we could predict who was
going to grow into a happy healthy
octogenarian
and who wasn't and when we gathered
together
everything we knew about them at age 50
it wasn't their middle-aged cholesterol
levels that predicted how they were
going to grow old
it was how satisfied they were in their
relationships
the people who were the most satisfied
in their relationships
at age 50 were the healthiest at age 80.
and good close relationships seem to
buffer us from some of the slings and
arrows of getting old
our most happily partnered men and women
reported in their 80s that on the days
when they had more physical pain
their moods stayed just as happy but the
people who were in
unhappy relationships on the days when
they reported more physical pain
it was magnified by more emotional pain
and the third big lesson that we learned
about relationships on our health
is that good relationships don't just
protect our bodies
they protect our brains it turns out
that being in a securely attached
relationship
to another person in your 80s is
protective
that the people who are in relationships
where they really feel they can count on
the other person
in times of need those people's memories
stay sharper
longer and the people in relationships
where they feel they really
can't count on the other one those are
the people who experience
earlier memory decline
and those good relationships they don't
have to be smooth all the time some of
our octogenarian couples
could bicker with each other day in and
day out
but as long as they felt that they could
really count on the other when the going
got tough
those arguments didn't take a toll on
their memories
so this message that
good close relationships are good for
our health and well-being
this is wisdom that's as old as the
hills why is this so hard to get
and so easy to ignore
well we're human what we'd really like
is a quick fix
something we can get that'll make our
lives good and keep them that way
relationships are messy and they're
complicated and
the hard work of tending to family and
friends
that's not sexy or glamorous it's also
lifelong
it never ends the people in our
75-year study who were the happiest in
retirement
were the people who had actively worked
to replace workmates
with new playmates just like the
millennials in that recent survey
many of our men when they were starting
out as young adults
really believed that fame and wealth and
high achievement were what they needed
to go
after to have a good life but over and
over over these 75 years our study has
shown
that the people who fared the best were
the people who
leaned into relationships with family
with friends with community
so what about you let's say you're 25
or you're 40 or you're 60 what
might leaning into relationships even
look like
well the possibilities are practically
endless
it might be something as simple as
replacing screen time with people time
or livening up a stale relationship by
doing something new together
long walks or date nights
or reaching out to that family member
who you haven't spoken to in years
because those all too common family
feuds
take a terrible toll on the people who
hold the grudges
i'd like to close with a quote from mark
twain
more than a century ago he was looking
back on his life
and he wrote this there isn't time
so brief is life for bickerings
apologies heart burnings callings to
account
there is only time for loving and but an
instant so to speak
for that the good life
is built with good relationships thank
[Applause]
you